mes amis ont dit que la vérité sort de
la bouche des enfants
lorsqu à l'école on a demandé à mon fils
c'est en ce qui ce que voulait dire le
mot république il a répondu naïvement la
france
ce n'était pas la réponse qu'attendent l
institutrice étaient pourtant au fond la
plus exacte
quand on vous demandera pourquoi vous
vous appelez républicain répondez vous
aussi que république c'est l'autre nom
de la france vous ne trouverez pas de
plus belle réponse que celle sortie de
la bouche de l'enfant auquel on n'a pas
encore appris l'histoire de france mais
qui en a déjà le pressentiment l'école
de la république celle de jules ferry et
des instituteurs d'autrefois donner à ce
sentiment la force nécessaire pour faire
un citoyen il ya cent ans quand un autre
enfant en blouse grise tourner la
dernière page de l'histoire de france
pour le cours élémentaire il pouvait
lire ces deux phrases dans ce livre tu
as appris l'histoire de france au cours
élémentaire
tu dois aimer la france parce que la
nature la fête belle et parce que son
histoire la fête grande on apprenait à
cet enfant que vercingétorix étaient
morts pour la patrie et que nos rois
avaient fait la france à l'enfant de la
campagne à celui des faubourgs ouvriers
à celui des beaux quartiers à celui des
colonies même on disait aux pères les
gaulois et que sainte blandine était
morte attaché à un poteau
le corps déchiqueté par les cornes des
taureaux en criant je suis chrétienne
chacun savait que les gaulois chacun
savait que les gaulois n'avait pas eu
tant de fils et tous se croyait pas que
le christ était le fils de dieu mais
tous communier dans la même histoire
tous étaient égaux dans cette communion
tous recevaient et en partagent le même
trésor de civilisation une langue une
littérature un art de prien de peindre
de sculpter de bâtir une façon de
regarder le monde est de penser cette
école à l'est de la singularité de la
culture à l'universalité de la science
et du savoir de l'amour
la patrie à l'amour du genre humain elle
nous a donné des poètes qui écrivait en
français des poèmes africains et des
poèmes martinique et elle a donné à la
france aux heures les plus gros des plus
grands périls des combattants
volontaires des résistants qui voulait
je les cite rendre à la france qu'elle
leur avait donné et les survivants qui
disait nous n'étions pas des héros nous
n'avons fait que notre devoir
nos pédagogues se moque de cette école
du tour de la france par deux enfants
vous savez le premier manuel scolaire
interdisciplinaire qui commençait et qui
finissaient par devoir et patrie il
accable de leur mépris le roman national
parce que ce qu'ils veulent apprendre à
nos enfants
c'est le roman noir de la nation celui
qui conduit à la repentance qui leur
fera comprendre que la réponse qui leur
fera comprendre que la repentance
produit la détestation de soi et que de
la détestation de soi la détestation des
autres il n'y a qu'un pas il ne faut
rien cacher les heures sombres font
aussi partie de notre histoire
mais ne faisons pas apporté à la france
les fautes qu'elle n'a pas commise la
france était la france libre vichy ce
n'était pas la france
france c'est vrai en ton nom à
permettrait de bien des crimes
république en ton nom c'est vrai on a
fait couler bien du sang nation entend
non c'est vrai on a déclaré bien des
guerres mais la gauche de la repentance
et de la guerre des mémoires gagnerait à
se remémorer les paroles de jaurès ce
qu'il faut 10 et j'aurai ce n'est pas
jugée toujours juger juger tout le temps
chaque époque doit être regardé en
elle-même dans ses moyens d'action et
dans son enchaînement naturel
c'est ainsi que nos enfants disent et
ils apprendront à connaître la france la
vraie france
la france qui n'est pas résumée dans une
époque où dans un jour la france qui est
tout entière dans la succession de
séjour de ces nuits de ses aurores de
ces crépuscule de ses montées de ces
chutes ainsi parlait jaurès
mais la gauche de la repentance et de la
guerre des mémoires celle du
communautarisme et du multiculturalisme
celle du retour des féodalités des
principautés celle qui cède à toutes les
minorités agissantes
c'est elle qui renie en même temps
l'héritage de la chrétienté celui des
lumières celle qui faisait la fête sur
la place de la bastille
le soir du 6 mai 2012 la gauche nilis
qui n'en a toujours pas fini avec mai 68
qui n'en finit plus de combattre contre
l'autorité et contre la nation cette
gauche-là cette gauche est devenue
étrangère à sa propre histoire
cette gauche les instituteurs socialiste
de mon enfance qui monte en a pris ne la
reconnaîtrait pas il y as est vrai une
gosse qui s'est toujours battu pour la
république
mais ce n'est pas françois mitterrand
autoproclamée en 1965 un candidat unique
des républicains contre le général de
gaulle qui avait sauvé deux fois la
république c'était le général de gaulle
ce ne sont pas ce ne sont pas les
héritiers de la gauche républicaine qui
nous gouvernent aujourd'hui ce sont les
héritiers de lagos qui criant 58 contre
le général de gaulle le fascisme ne
passera pas et de la gauche qui à
charléty en 1968 attendait avec
gourmandise que la rue fasse tomber le
pouvoir dans ses mains comme un fruit
mûr malraux avait dit les politiciens
forme d'un syndicat de négociateur il
n'avait pas tort
ceux qui nous gouvernent font beaucoup
mieux ils forment un syndicat de
liquidateurs ils liquident la famille
l'école les professions libérales les
communes rurales les départements la
nationalité l'autorité aller
du passé faisons table rase vieille
histoire
ils ne sentent plus l'international il
se moque bien des damnés de la terre
mais dans leur pensée il y a toujours ce
rêve fou de l'homme nouveau
sans attaches sans famille sans patrie
plus de transmission plus méritants
voilà ce que veut dire pour le mot
émancipation les abaisser de l'égalité
la théorie du genre le droit à l'enfant
pour tous
et tant pis
s'il faut pour cela mettre aux enchères
le ventre des femmes
le bac pour tous et tant pis s'ils ne
vont plus rien la culture inclusive je
cite le ministre de la culture au lieu
de la culture cultivée et tant pis pour
la culture tout le monde sous la toise
pas de différence voilà ce que veut dire
pour eux le mot égalité liquide est la
nation les kids est la nation voilà ce
que veut dire pour eux le mot fraternité
liquidateur de tous les pays unissez
vous sauf que les autres ne valent rien
l'idée du tout en tout cas pas la nation
ni les frontières
il n'y a qu'en europe qu'on en rêve on
croit que sans frontières et sans nation
on aura la paix tant pis si les peuples
ne sont pas d'accord mais quand on
abaisse la nation on ne récolte que le
nationalisme un député européen
socialiste disait hier matin à la radio
les français ont cru que l'europe serait
la france en grand ce ne sera pas le cas
il faut que les français apprennent à
voir les choses autrement
j'ai envie de lui répondre et sinon
sinon si l'europe nous condamne à la
france en petit alors il nous faut nous
dépêcher de changer d'europe imaginer le
monde sans les nations sans les
frontières la paix non la guerre de tous
contre tous
la loi de la jungle des tribus pas de
nation pas de frontières alors pas de
droits des peuples pas de démocratie pas
de sécurité sociale pas de république
n'ont plus personne pour défendre la
liberté le droit au milieu des désordres
du monde
la grande affaire politique de notre
temps c'est la nation
ma famille politique mes amis c'est le
gaullisme ma république c'est la
république gaullienne ma france et la
france libre l'indépendance nationale la
souveraineté nationale celle des
résistants dont malraux disait qu'il se
battait pour cette fierté mystérieuse
dont il ne savait au fond aucune chose
c'était qu'à leurs yeux la france avait
perdu la france une et indivisible
celle de tous les français celles d'un
seul peuple
celle qui regarde dans le grand lit
je vais vers l'avenir sans jamais rien
oublié de son passé et lormont aurore
c'est l'europe européenne des peuples et
des nations
mon école c'est celle qui apprend à
chaque enfant à penser par lui-même et à
respecter l'autorité avant de la
contester celle des internats
d'excellence celle du mérite et de la
reconnaissance du talent la seule
capable d'offrir sa chance à chaque
enfant mon école c'est celle qui fait
partager à tous un imaginaire commun qui
permettra de se comprendre et de ses
mets mon école c'est celle qui apprend à
aimer la littérature à aimer la poésie à
aimer ce qui est grand et ce qui est
beau à aimer la france parce qu'elle est
grande et parce qu'elle est belle on ne
comprend jamais mieux on ne comprend
jamais mieux ce qui est un gaulliste
qu'on fasse un anti gaulliste un anti
gaulliste voyez vous c'est quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas la france et qui pense que
son rôle dans l'histoire est terminée
le gaullisme se bat toujours contre la
politique politicienne qui contourne
l'obstacle
il a ce biais au corps l'inébranlable
conviction que la politique c'est la
volonté humaine dans l'histoire
la volonté humaine par la volonté de
puissance la république se bat toujours
contre les féodalités qui veulent
confisquer la souveraineté du peuple
le gaullisme c'est l'autre nom du
sentiment national la république c'est
l'autre nom de la france ils ont pour
ennemi le fanatisme l'obscurantisme qui
n'ont de sens les ruines de palmyre les
gorges des chrétiens d'orient détruit à
coups de marteau avec des bulldozer les
vestiges d'une civilisation qui a dix
mille ans honneur à nos soldats
honneur à tous ceux qui meurent pour une
si juste cause ils ont pour ennemi
l'ignorance et l'inculture
ils ont en point pour ennemi le mensonge
et de cynisme ils ont pour la nuit
l'argent fou et la mort 110 nations du
monde
ils ont pour ennemi la lâcheté et le
rhône en ce moment et enfants gaulliste
c'est l'autre nom de républicains il y a
des mots dit le poète ce qu'ils font
vivre et ce sont des mots innocent le
mot chaleur et le mot confiance amour
justice et le mot liberté
le mot enfant et le mot gentillesse le
mot courage et le mot découvrir et
certains noms de pays de village
j ajouterai bien moins le mot france et
le mot république la république c'est la
france il enfants je te garderai l'une
et l'autre dit le père ami nous
partirons tout à l'heure en chantant la
marseillaise
chacun avec notre façon d'aimer la
france d'aimer la république ayant dans
notre pensée des visages de républicains
qui ne seront pas les mêmes
les miens rond le visage de jacques
chaban delmas de pierre semaine mère de
michel debré de charles pasqua et de
philippe séguin
je penserai au général de gaulle à
georges pompidou andré malraux
mais tous tous amis nous aurons
conscience de la gravité de l'heure et
que notre devoir est grand puisque il ne
s'agit rien moins pour nous que de
contribuer à sauver ce qui peut encore
être sauvée d'une certaine idée de
l'homme ami ami c'était une arme et il
avait du courage
quelques fusils quelques canaux la
victoire en chantant on leur a ouvert la
barrière la liberté à guider leurs pas
nous sommes une armée sans aucune arme
s'ajoute une autre arme que la force de
notre conviction est celle de l'exemple
nous n'avons à conquérir que des
intelligences et des coeurs mais la
victoire en son temps nous ouvrir à la
barrière et la liberté nous guidera nos
pains amis républicains
aujourd'hui la république nous appelle
merci nicolas de nous avoir réunis
merci nous avons engagé dans ce combat